[Music]
to climb the green wall just yet Oshima
tries to do something he's the only one
that laughs and his good name good
damage positional rush you didn't see
him he don't wait just keep this alive
it's down to him and mix well he's got
bomb inside of the site good read as
well no mix Wells gone to war doubter
preset crosshair great pixel aim through
the bottle across wired he's got to be
spotted back away from it still eyes
positional control from the ground
through the smoke that's disgusting
so hard to attack in this position tops
anyway he's looking beyond for the ACE
right now if he's able to catch fallen
closest what's handy now the games being
given up they know it fallen is he has
to hit the shot quickly still has no
idea spinning around are so fast Phelps
denied the ACE 2.0 the triple comes in
fallen why are you so good at this game
Pyrus reactions is requiring positioning
against them it rocks the bomb
temporarily as well as apex Falls two
ports
gasp says it all because that gives away
the advantage they have Kenny's forced
to go high on the ground with the
bullets all below it's just happy
remaining is this position good enough
though he doesn't want to push him
behind because he expects I'm gonna be
watching if they're gonna drop in do
they check it they will now they will
fold oh that's happy damaged on its
bolts down to 80 HP he may just have
enough in this position to hold it off
he'll do exactly that as they pick up
their first in overtime it won't be one
night bomb ticking away he might have a
chance in this one flashes early flash
in return and on the defuse immediately
down to three seconds KGB's got it Wow
oh goodness gracious via glaive is going
absolutely nuts three players still
standing for Australis what a defense oh
my stuck in CT spawn that was ridiculous
he's in separate kills as well for it
might be one bullet this is this round
is completely insane very exposed plant
ages he tried cross for 25 HP but a
smoke is down so he's good he's running
out of time as long as no way but a
crazy
that's one of the most explosive breath
so think I'll see low HP as well it's
not looking great perfect in pretty much
every situation no matter where he comes
in he gets a jump on him if he walks in
from the window above it becomes around
the corner from stairs comes a monster
and he's kind of lined up but first one
timing there it is though exactly that
device still has headshot angle and
another round for astralis 10 to 1
that's a saving grace in the play spots
the low HP toward highways well Lucas
falls bomb down in front smokes
according to pick that up I don't think
he's gonna go for a default you can't
possibly elect to do so because steel
can easily spray through first he's
gotta check out the garage he thinks
this is gonna be a flank play he's got a
little bit of time to work with you
evaluate on 16 seconds and he's gonna
expose himself steel squats a nasty a
shot with a deagle though not easy task
from that range an NB k1 bullets all it
takes doesn't matter what weapon it is
as managed at least to get the ball down
flashover he wants to get aggressive
knows he's pushed off
Turner clutches it back for enemies to
tie the game really intelligent clutter
from MDK low HP you see the awareness of
it